here we go and spread the word you can  make butter faster than you can make  toast three two one Chan oh man  Jun Jin Chun times already tired Chen  Chen Chuck it's so hard right now thanks  the butter and the verdict  nice spreadable butter it's pretty cool  it's a whole bottle of awesome Mike but  how can you make butters so fast cream  is an emulsion and emotion is one thing  suspended in another in a cream it's fat  suspended in mostly water  that's as hydrophobic which means it  really doesn't play nicely with water  the water and the fat in milk just don't  mix very well this means that fat exists  in these small islands it is thirst all  the way through the water as they shake  the cream the fat globules start moving  around and eventually one gravel can  find another and they stick together the  end result is a large blob of butter and  buttermilk on the side which is mainly  water brilliant though is a legendary  you just went there didn't you soos yeah  I win